hey folks and we are back here at the
GameSpot stage at e3 2014 once again
I'm your host Sean McGuinness and I've
got mark Dara from Bioware the executive
producer
that's right agent position mark thanks
for joining us good to be here so you
guys have been getting pretty good
amount of buzz so far here yeah it's
been really three for us yeah we've been
trolling a lot of games so it's been
getting a lot of good vibes I mean it
people seem to have responded really
well to the direction that you guys are
going with Dragon Age Inquisition which
is which in my estimation if I had to
describe it in a nutshell which is just
blow up the game expand the scale and
give it the kind of like visual identity
that it's never really had in the past
this like really really intriguing art
style while just expanding the whole
thing right now really I mean this is in
a way really the Dragon Age game we've
always been trying to make or wanting to
make we just haven't had the time or the
scale to do it so we're literally at
this one trying to bring exploration
back to a Bioware game so we have that
core story that we're known for with the
characters and relationships that that
really draw you in but now we can give
you a lot more space to explore and
immerse yourself in a world all right
great now if you guys have any questions
feel free to respond in the GameSpot
chat that we have going on right here or
send them my way on Twitter I am at NASA
McGinnis let's take a look at the
footage that you guys have brought along
here can you describe this particular
area yeah so this is actually the
hinterlands it's actually an area that's
just outside of Red Cliff Village for
people that are familiar with Dragon Age
this area is bigger than all of Dragon
Age Origins put together and it's one of
just a multitude of regions that were
actually having in Dragon Age
Inquisition so this is a more settled
area but it's actually in the grips of
conflict between the mages and the
templars you'll see that right here
mages and Templars are kind of going at
it down there but we'll take you to less
explored areas frostback mountains out
into out into bogs and deep desert what
the thing is is that for Dragon Age
Inquisition the scope of the story is so
big that we needed the breadth of
terrain we we're crossing two nations so
we couldn't just have one region we
needed to be able to pull it out and
just have it be able to go where it
needed to go from the
retelling perspective so one of the
tricky things about you know big open
games is that scale alone doesn't make
things interesting you need that
emergent gameplay and all the little
in-between areas when you're not doing a
critical mission so in terms of what you
guys are doing with Inquisition what's
the incentive to just explore and take
things at your own pace yeah I mean
you're absolutely right about about
open-world gameplay for us what we
really make sure is that every area you
go to is important to the story you're
doing things to further the the power of
the Inquisition this is an organization
that you ultimately lead and it gives
you the power to do things you wouldn't
otherwise be able to do you reach a
fortress the doors are locked behind you
you can't sneak in the back you have you
have troops you 100 guys that you can
use to bash the door and to get you
through that front door and ultimately
what you're doing the exploration is
things that are either going to make you
better
so gathering crafting materials in order
to make yourself better armor and arms
or you're doing things that are actually
furthering the renown and power of the
Inquisition to draw people to your cause
all right so we're starting to get quite
a flood of questions here
Maximillian on twitter is asking about
the controls in the game because you
know from Dragon Age Origins to Dragon
Age 2 you guys quicken the pace a little
bit may the action a little bit more
immediate and quick what are you guys
doing with Inquisition so we're doing
two things there it were we're slowing
down the animation to be a little more
weight a little bit more grounded in the
world so when a guys swinging a
two-handed sword he's not spinning
around as much yeah
he's a little bit more grounded the
other thing is is that we're bringing
back tactile camera on all five
platforms so it was just on PC for
Dragon Age Origins didn't exist on
Dragon Age 2 at all here you're going to
be able to pull the camera back really
look at the battlefield consider what
you're doing
and and really give those that really
fine control if you want to do that
you'll also be able to control the game
completely in real time if if that's a
playstyle you prefer now what is the
reason behind bringing that tactical
camera back is it just something that
you are able to do now that you got more
time and you can fine-tune it
yeah it's partially that it's partially
just that ultimately this is a game mode
leadership this is a game about
about controlling a group both the
Inquisition but also your party and they
just felt very much even just from a
storytelling thematic respect it was a
very appropriate thing to bring back all
right let's see here a lot of a lot of
questions about romance options yeah we
always get a lot of questions about
romance options so let's just just
describe it in a nutshell because
Bioware has always been very progressive
about that type of thing and giving just
players options and not forcing them to
live their character in a very
particular way I mean that I think
options are is a very good way to put it
we definitely want to make sure that you
have as much control over the way you
play your character and the way you
interact with other people so that does
mean romances are totally optional
you're not we're going to try to make it
as clear as possible when you're when
you're crossing that line so you're not
stumbling into a romantic option by out
by mistake all right yeah I mean I still
remember in Dragon Age Origins and this
might be too but Dragon Age Origins
walking into the brothel them asking
what you prefer male or female what the
third option was surprised me yes so
it's always been that kind of game yes
let's see here if some questions about
importing saves from previous games so
the way that works is a Dragon Age
Inquisition is definitely a great place
to pick up the series if you haven't
played before the wait what we're doing
is we have a web service called the
Dragon Age key which you can go to and
actually build a save essentially build
your choices from the previous two games
using an interactive form it's amazing
closed beta right now we're going to be
expanding that out over the summer
all right so and is that give you kind
of like a little story primer in case I
forget it was details exactly if you
really want to be brought if you haven't
played dragon before and you really
really want to be a up-to-date on the on
the world the Dragon Age keep is going
to give you an opportunity to really
figure seeing what happened in the
previous two games all right so we're
actually taking a look at a big epic
dragon battle right now yeah we'd be
remiss if we didn't talk about that a
little bit yeah so I mean I think we
actually were distracted we're kind of
actually pretty hard
yeah so I mean dragons are dragons are
actually the biggest baddest things
they're really endgame content they're
apex predators you really need to bring
your game when you're going to fight
them they one thing we've introduced for
Dragon Age Inquisition is multiple
target regions so now you're not just
attacking a big sort of sphere of damage
you can attack their legs if you do
enough damage they're going to roll over
onto their side giving you access to
their head to really to really do a lot
more damage so and you said that they
are endgame enemies what type of enemies
are we going to be encountering along
the progression sword strike oh one of
the things we're doing in in this game
is we're not Auto balancing the game
which means like in the in the very
first area in there's ad right there
will be a dragon there and if you want
to go and try to take them on at level 5
you can do that it's probably going to
be a bad idea but we're going to really
open up and make it leave it to the
player to really decide what they deeply
want to engage a lot of a lot of
humanoid creatures obviously this is
very much a game that has a lot of
people and politics in it but the game
at its fundamental core is about this
breach in the sky which spitting demons
out so a lot of demons you're going to
see over the course of the game all
right now abdel-rahman
cash on Twitter is asking about types of
dragons variety is it sort of like just
that one singular dragon in the distance
that you're working towards or is it
sort of various types there are various
types of dragons we actually have dragon
legs as well sort of the younger dragons
but we'll be doing dragons differentiate
by element like essentially like fire
breath or ice breath as well as a few
other sort of regional variations based
on where in the world you actually are
all right let's see so many very very
specific questions about Dragon Age
that's the kind of community that you
guys that's the community we have he has
very specific questions about about Lily
Anna's haircut or something else right
yes so how do you filter that kind of
stuff how do you take just that wealth
of feedback from the community
and use that to inform the direction of
the game yeah I mean it's really
important to be open to these kinds of
questions and and to try to respond as
best we can obviously we don't want to
answer questions that are going to spoil
the story I mean even though you people
think they want the answer some of these
questions there's some that the answer
is not going to be it's going to it's
going to wreck things for them so we
have to be careful about what we do and
do not answer right right of course
let's see we're getting questions about
platforms of the game specifically what
we're seeing here can you tell do you
have to know what platform this is yeah
so this was actually captured on a PC
with a with a controller we will have
full PC mouse and keyboard controls as
well and then and then and then like
Xbox one and ps4 will have really high
graphical fidelity as well ps3 and
xbox360 are obviously going to have a
little bit lag behind a little bit there
yeah yeah
any plans for modding support on the PC
version um
maybe we've talked about it obviously
this game uses frostbite 3 so that's
something that doesn't currently exist
for that engine but it is something we
have talked about and so not at launch
right and even if it's not official the
Dragon Age community tends to be pretty
active they'll they'll definitely figure
it out we've seen Dragon Age 2 stuff
where we didn't have an official toolset
that it has shown up for sure let's see
uh what
so okay so we talked about the importing
of Saves and how you guys are building
that tool to create your own save file
in case you don't have that on you know
in case you don't have that anymore but
in terms of what you're importing how
much does that affect the events of
Dragon Age Inquisition Jared Richard on
Twitter is actually asking about this
yeah so one thing that Dragon Age has
always been about it's much more about
the world and the time than it is about
a specific character so the what that
means is the really there's there's
there's sort of choices you've made that
matter for the world choices you've made
that matter for characters and those are
very important so you know who's the
king from Dragon Age Origins that's
really important ultimately who the
warden romanced that's actually
important too because we have characters
the return it's important that to know
if Morgan we had a relationship with
that with that warden character but some
of the other choices you made
maybe we're mattered in the moments but
didn't matter over to the overall state
of the world so we're importing hundreds
of choices from the previous games so
it's a lot all right Marc well I
appreciate your time and I'd like to
apologize to the 900 people whose
questions we didn't get to - yeah I mean
we'll try to answer them as best we can
all right great so there you guys have
it that was your look at Dragon Age
Inquisition courtesy of our friend Marc
Terra from Bioware